que de chemin parcouru depuis la toute
première édition et je m'en souviens
c'était à basse terre avec lucien jean
baptiste comme président du jury et nous
avions à l'époque vraiment pris un vrai
pari et qui savait en huit ans après en
passe d'être gagné parce que l'enjeu
dont disions à l'époque était déjà de
faire éclore de nouveaux talents et nous
rendrons compte à l'occasion de cette
huitième édition que les talents sont
bien présents et pour le cinéma
antillais c'est une merveilleuse
nouvelle
elle a réussi à fédérer dès le départ
consistait à amener le maximum de jeunes
dans ces métiers de la création vers
l'ouverture et le cinéma
oui parce qu'on se rend compte que
l'engouement est là il y a de plus en
plus des oeuvres qui sont présentées
elles sont de plus en plus qualitative
et surtout je crois que nous avons une
opportunité aujourd'hui de pouvoir avec
des talents comme bassin vers mignon qui
a été présent dans plusieurs oeuvres a
pris de court comme des réalisateurs
comme marc acquis une crise qui fait
aussi le très bel terrière ou linda
d'alexis donc nous avons petit à petit
ce que j'appelle une team une team pris
de court qui est en train petit à petit
de s'imposer comme étant une nouvelle
référence pour les sardines et antillo
guyanais et je pense que nous sommes au
delà même de promesses que nous ayons
envie d'être là de la question ça reste
toujours un festival sur les trois
départements guadeloupe antilles guyane
aussi d'italie
c'est vraiment le challenge de ce
festival c'est une est effectivement
antillo guyanais est itinérante à dire
qu'il se déroule partout en même temps
pour les trois territoires et en même
temps avec une alternance donc ça veut
dire que en termes d'organisation c'est
chaque fois une espèce de point ce qu'a
réalisé et je salue toutes les équipes
de pris de court grâce à grâce auquel
nous pouvons effectivement présenté ce
festival du bit